So far, we've learned what happens when we substitute in special values of x
that make the function equal to zero. And we've seen that this connects
directly to factors. Now we're going to look at how to find special values,
like a in this case. Working backwards from what we have written here, if we
could look at a function and find its factors, then we would know these special
values. So let's figure out how to do that. Now you already know how to factor
quadratic expressions and you had a lot of practice with that earlier in the
course. So let's see if we can look at another function and use similar methods
to this to find one factor and then figure out what that factor needs to be
multiplied by to give us the original function. Let's say we have a function
that's already in factored form maybe it's f of x equals x minus 6 times x plus
2 times x minus 4. If this is the case and we decide to multiply this right
hand side out, and then simplify, what is the constant term that we'll get? Now
what you want to be looking for here is a shortcut to do this. So that you
don't have to actually multiply out everything. Think about which combinations
of terms here are going to give us just constants.